the city's longest serving battalion
chief is
preparing to retire next week lawrence
wycliffe has served the las vegas valley
for nearly 50 years
reporter kate houston sat down with him
to look back at his career
i've had some of the largest highway
incidents
largest configuration type fires after
46 years
las vegas fire battalion chief lawrence
wickliffe is about to retire
wycliff started in the mid 70s when he
decided to enroll in training
freshly out of college this was his
first profession and he was determined
to go far
when the fire chief interviewed me when
i first got hired he said
where do you see yourself going in the
fire service i said
your chair throughout his career he saw
the department go through many changes
when i got hired women were not on the
job
and i guess i became a woman's advocate
as one of very few african americans on
the job
he made an impact on the community i've
had people
literally come up in the middle of a
fire
that i was incident commander they
wanted to know
if i was a firefighter because they
never seen a black
guy running a fire or in charge
throughout his career he's responded to
emergencies that put las vegas into the
international spotlight
such as one october the pep con
explosion and mgm
fire i was out in front of the building
just starting ivs and
patient assessment without even going
through
the hospital codes because it was just
too many people
after nearly five decades of service he
says he's most proud of the men and
women he worked with in his battalion
and his ability to provide for his
family but i would like to see
us as a group or an organization be the
uniting
factor to help solve some of our
country's
differences because it's a profession
that takes care of you and care for you
and it has nothing to do with race
has nothing to do with gender it's all
about
you as a human being kate houston 8 news
now